érik rémès bonsoir alors là attention
vous avez 38 ans vous êtes titulaire
d'une maîtrise de psychologie clinique
et de philosophie et vous êtes également
journaliste voulait travailler pour
guêpier libération nova et vous avez
déjà publié deux livres je bande donc je
suis consacré au sm guet pendant les
années sida et le maître d amour qui
raconte votre expérience de ma soeur
prostituées les bisexuels attention aux
yeux maman va te coucher je te jure
maintenant c'est mieux alors là et vous
publiées aujourd'hui aux éditions
blanche série all fucker journal d'un
bear baker
[Musique]
un décret mais ce qu'est ce qu'un bébé
coeur alors barbe à coeur c'est une
personne séropositive qui désirent avoir
des rapports sexuels non protégés avec
d'autres barback heures avec d'autres
personnes séropositives
il ya aussi une forme plus radicale qui
le barde hackers qui veut contaminer les
personnes séronégatives coeur voilà et
ben moi j'ai voulu un petit peu traité
tous problèmes l'arrêté du problème des
becker alors c'est vrai qu'à l'origine
ça veut dire chevauchés à cru on en
faisait un terme américains américain
voilà ce qui veut dire baiser sans
capote on voit la voix est alors dans la
communauté gay chez les berbères coeur
en tous les cas il ya un véritable culte
des relations non protégées tout à fait
les bonnes choses heures c'est à dire
ceux qui désirent être affectés par le
virus et il ya les gift beavers donc
c'est les donneurs de cadeau et il ya
vraiment de plus en plus de personnes
qui ont des pratiques à risque les
statistiques sont exponentielles chaque
année que moi il fait donc il ya ça il
ya un culte du sperme s'il ya du sperme
tout à fait voilà un qui des muqueuses
du des glaires voilà et puis aussi les
rapports impersonnel multiples dans les
bateaux les backrooms voilà donc ça
c'est vraiment la définition complète
gibert baker vous suivez astrid
alors est ce que tous les bébés coeur
sont séropositifs comme vous alors les
libère bakker deviennent forcément un
jour ou l'autre séropositive c'est ça le
problème parce que c'est quand même une
maladie qui est grave qui peut être
mortelle
ouais voilà donc qu'il faut c'est un peu
le jeu de la roulette russe aussi oui
alors vous vous êtes devenus
séropositifs à l'âge de 24 ans voudrait
dans votre bouquin prendre un premier x
aller à la gym se faire un cas tous de
venir c'est repos c'est le parcours
classique du jeune bd parisien normal
voilà c'est moi mon lycée un livre comme
radicale dont il ya vaincu de phrases à
l'emporte-pièce et beaucoup de phrases
un peu humoristique comme le sida parce
que je le vaux bien
1 vous mourir du sida que d'ennui donc
c'est un humour très noir très cynique
saint-renan assez violent qui est assez
dur à lire et qui est pas évident et qui
est qu'un documentaire assez
exceptionnel pour ne serait ce que pour
les hétérosexuels de de savoir comment
les gay vivant tout cas c'est la
meilleure publicité pour la capote parce
que quand on a lu vos neuf
on n'a qu'une envie de se protéger et
fantaisie de subventions il a loupé
a contrario alors quand vous avez eu les
résultats de votre test quand vous avez
appris que vous étiez positif vous avez
fait une tentative de suicide
vous êtes resté deux jours dans le coma
et quand cette sortie de l'hosto vous
avez planté un couteau de cuisine
donc dans le dos de votre mari le
couteau s'est cassé vous êtes battus
ensuite les flics sont arrivés et vous
terminez et voilà c'est fini
oui le coup de couteau en plus c'est un
couteau solide et par chance il s'est
cassé arrive mais sinon il serait mort
sinon il serait mort il serait en prison
oui ça fait pas rire ah non ça me fait
marrer c'est grave vraiment mais c'est
super grave
ouais mais il faut moi je pense qu'en
fin si ça fait 14 ans que je suis
séropositif et je suis encore en vie
c'est que c'est aussi que j'ai su
positiver les choses et ne pas tout
prendre dramatique il pouvoir en rire ni
et dans serial fucker
j'essaye de rire de tout et je pense
qu'il faut rire de tout comme on peut
rire des [ __ ] comme on peut rire des
juifs aussi oui par exemple quand vous
dites alors vous pouvez dire que c'est
le personnage du roman et je sais pas
vous mais quand vous infecter sciemment
à un garçon qui s'appelle pierre sous
prétexte qu'il est con et prétentieux et
que vous rajouter c'est un service à lui
rendre
pour donner un sens à sa vie c'est quand
même un excuse moi c'est un crime de
détraqués ya pas y'a pas d'autre mode
enfin c'est pas jouer les moralistes
mais c'est un crime c'est un roman oui
il a marqué roman quand il a marqué
roman est tout à fait donc je dis pas
que j'ai fait j'ai pratiqué ces choses
là j'ai même façon il ya beaucoup de
gens éventuellement que j'aurais
contaminée qui auraient été contaminés
ailleurs de toute façon donc enfin ça
vous est arrivé de faire l'amour avec
des gens négatifs en sachant que vous
pourriez les rendre visite il a vu
solutions par exemple si on veut rentrer
ensemble ce soir
oui soit je vous ai dit que je suis
séropositif
si vous voulez pas qu'on mette des
capotes je suis
je ne vais pas en remettre deuxième
solution c'est qu'on n'a pas parlé de
mon état sérologique
sinon tu voulais pas utiliser de capotes
moi je suis pas responsable du désir que
vous avez pour moi ou pour d'autres
personnes
ch en direct vous êtes séropositif si la
personne ne le demande pas non enfin
parce que c'est à la personne de prendre
ses responsabilités aussi si on se
protège pour soi je sais que ça fait ça
fait ça fait bondir tout le monde moi je
suis pas un monstre mais c'est à chacun
de se protéger pour lui même il ya aussi
des gens qui désirent contaminer les
autres
que ce soit des hétéros ou décès ou des
homos voix et le personnage secondaire
dans serial fucker c'est une femme
hétérosexuelle nina qui s'amusent à
contaminer d'autres personnes
hétérosexuelles parce qu'elle a été
violée dans son enfance par son père
voilà donc faut se méfier
voilà c'est un message aussi de
prévention radical que je fais oui il ya
une scène terrible avec un mec marié qui
vient à faire l'amour sans capote et qui
s'est infectée et en plus le personnage
ou vous j'en sais plus rien mais vous
dites je savais pas encore pour ma
rechute de syphilis entre le mec qui
risquent de se choper le sida et la
syphilis le même soir je sens que j'en
crois que ça fait bondir la salle
malheureusement alors dirais qu'il ya de
plus en plus de barback heures qui en
fait ne pratique plus le sexe sans
capote parce que justement il se tape
des blennorragie des syphilis et
d'autres maladies camions qui préfèrent
ils préfèrent éviter d'avoir des
rapports à risque quoi il y en a aussi
qui perd ses capotes c'est terrible ça
ouais alors ça c'est ça c'est une rumeur
c'est une rumeur urbaine qui s'accusent
depuis une quinzaine d'années et
effectivement ça peut exister c'est des
trucs qu'on voit sur internet connaît
que les capotes vaut mieux les veaux
les surveiller quoi on a apporté aussi
c'est aussi valable pour les
hétérosexuels maintenant le premier
groupe à risque ce n'est pas les [ __ ]
qu'on soit clair
le premier regroupe à risque il ya 40%
des gens qu'ils sont hétérosexuels
donc ça concerne tu es gamin ça concerne
vos frères ça concerne vos parents c'est
pas un truc pour les [ __ ] les toxicos
de signal or vous raconter des trucs
incroyables dans ce bouquin par exemple
les couples qui quand il y en a un des
deux qui n'est pas séropositif il
partage partage virus à ramous renouer
padres la ville est complètement avec
l'autre parce que c'est vrai que pour
avoir une sexe pour être pour être dans
une relation intime une relation intime
à long terme avec préservatif c'est
difficile à tenir et c'est vrai qu'il ya
plein de séronégatifs qui par amour de
leur partenaire préfère devenir sert
pour effectivement non est ce que vous
connaissez des gens qui sciemment
infecte des gens qui sont séronégatifs
par vengeance pas par haine de la
société ou simplement parce qu'ils sont
positifs et ça les fait flipper serial
fucker moi je les écris pour ce à quoi
pour montrer qu'il ya des choses aussi
radicale qui existent quoi parce que les
très jeunes l'indicé
j'ai entendu une histoire d'une gamine
de 18 ans c'est une amie de ma petite
fiole qui a doit avoir 17 ans
effectivement il ya un de ses potes qui
a fait l'amour avec une jeune fille qui
a dit qu'elle était vierge et en fait
elle était contaminée et lui a dit
sciemment que c'était le seul danger
quoi l'histoire du premier mois je pense
que quand on a 16 17 15 ans et qu'on a
un premier rapport sexuel on n'est pas
du tout habitués et là faut vraiment
faire attention quoi ça existe tu savais
que ça existe et francis à toi tu
connaissais
dit que tout existe j'ai écrit ce
bouquin en fait parce que au départ
j'étais attaqué suite à mon premier
roman je pense donc je suis par act up
paris qui ont fait des affiches pendant
la gay pride où il mettait que les
bouquins de guillaume dustan à érik
rémès était ainsi théo barback donc
ensuite on nous a traité de criminel on
nous a traités d'irresponsables on nous
a traités d'assassins
ensuite il ya même un président d'act up
qui nous a traités de grenade sexuel ce
cas les faits jean-marie le pen en nous
traitant de bons bacs bactériologique
le problème c'est que c'est l'épée d eux
mêmes qui ce qui deviendra sister act up
paris en l'occurrence
donc moi j'ai voulu faire un bouquin là
dessus et le sida excusez moi mais c'est
quand même après textes littéraires
formidable le bareback sa touche à la
vie à la mort au désir à la sexualité à
l'amour et c'est quand même un texte
littéraire formidable en même temps moi
le sida ce n'est pas une obsession du
terrain mon deuxième roman le masseur
prostituées il était séronégatif n'y a
pas que le sida dans la vie non plus ok
on peut pratiquer le light my fire
oui c'est qu'on fait on fait l'amour au
fumoir côté d'une bassine de kérosène ça
s'en vient à saint bien ça c'est là
qu'on fait c'est la bombe
mais il ya un truc encore pire c'est le
bohec non quand vous appuyez le pancake
ça non mais ça c'est en fait c'est un
terme pour nous tu dois connaître sa
dont les noms c'est un gang bang buccale
voila voila je suis
la grosse mais ciani
dans une communauté
monsieur
bref les rires non c'est un jeu c'est ce
qu'un gang borg et là c'est un gang bang
du caje éjaculation faciale
oui parce qu'on parle dans deux banques
belges excusez moi mais par mick jagger
ou machin je n'y a pas plusieurs en même
temps après l'autre à abobo tout lui
dire aujourd hui une flûte de port louis
un truc alors sérieusement là pour
conclure
est-ce que vous pensez que vous êtes une
publicité formidable pour la capote ce
que je disais tout à l'heure où au
contraire que vous allez donner à des
gens grâce à vos bouquins à vos passages
à la télé à la radio
finalement des idées terrible c'est à
dire que au lieu de sérieux le flanker
clair c'est clair c'est formidablement
clair son discours est et attend bien
sûr ccg n'ya bien sûr c'est un écrivain
c'est en toute chose
ces nobles littéraire artistique quoi
mais moi ce qui m'a fait ce qui m'a fait
me radicaliser dans l'opposition c'est
des attaques sur le fait que là il ya
une espèce d'omerta dans le milieu gay
qu'on ne peut plus dire certaines choses
je suis sur la liste noire de thé dessus
ils veulent pas parler du bouquin parce
qu'ils ont peur parce que c'est les
mêmes gens qu'act up
donc il ya une vraie omerta à au mot à
la bouche la seule librairie gay je suis
vendu avec un bandeau nous sommes en
désaccord total avec le contenu de ce
livre
excusez moi donc il ya vraiment une
forme de censure les [ __ ] deviennent
totalement normative à l'avoir gégène
histoire
ils veulent avoir des gamins ils veulent
bientôt les [ __ ] vont être aussi
j'allais dire aussi triste que les
hétéros alors que non mais non m
l'homosexualité
sexualité doit rester quand même quelque
chose ou subversif est créatif
sinon à quoi ça c'est loin de genre je
n'ai cessé de dire et moi ma référence
c'est jean genet mois voilà et g le
guide michelin on n'est pas que j'aie de
grossir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu